딱히 예의 없거나 무례한 것도 아닌데
그냥 묘하게 친해지기 싫은 사람이 있지 않나요?
이번 5분 레벨업에서는
두 권의 참고서를 바탕으로
딱히 잘못한 건 없지만
그냥 친해지기 싫은 사람의 특징
두 가지를 알려드릴게요
1. 틱톡톡
첫 번째, 부분 긍정, 담아 표지
대놓고 무례한 건 아니지만
이 사람하고는 왠지 친해지고 싶지 않은데
라고 생각들게 만드는 사람의
특징이 뭔지 아시나요?
그 특징은 바로
아, 저기 저랑 같이 교양 듣는 분 맞죠?
네? 아, 네 맞는 것 같아요
어, 혹시 이거 관심 있으시면 여연락 주세요
아, 아내 근대제가 이제 졸업반이라
시간이 없긴 한데
저도 4학년인데요, 뭘
고전영화동아리?
혹시 예술대분이세요?
아니요, 상경대인데요
오, 그렇구나
뭔가 좀 특이하시다
뭐, 메이저한 취미는 아니죠
오, 근데 이런 동아리 활동은
자서서 준비할 때
도움이 되죠?
도움이 돼서 하시는 거예요?
왠지 친해지기 꺼려지는 사람의
특징은
아, 아니 그렇다기보다는
그냥 제가 재밌어서 하는 건데요
오, 오 그렇구나
뭐 뭔가 낭만 있으신데요?
아, 아니 그게 아니라
그냥 제가 아직 철이 덜 든 거죠 뭐
대조의 담아 표지를
자주 사용한다는 겁니다
담아 표지는
말뜻에는 직접적인 영향을 주지 않지만
화자의 의도를 더욱
명확하게 전달해주는 역할을 합니다
예를 들어
그럼으로는
인과관계를
정리하자면은
요약을
아니, 그게 아니라
그렇다기보다는
대조를 나타내는
담아 표지입니다
담아 표지는
일상적으로
정말 자주 사용하는
유명한 도구입니다
하지만 대조의 담아 표지만큼은
너무 자주 사용하면
매력적인 대화 상대가 될 수 없다는
치명적인 단점이 있습니다
그렇기 때문에
오, 근데 이런 동아리 활동은
자서서 준비할 때
도움이 돼서 하시는 거예요?
상대방이 한 말을
바로잡고 싶다고
대조의 담아 표지를
사용하기보다는
네, 그렇기도 한데
근데 사실 전
그냥 제가 재밌어서 하는 거예요
그렇기도 하고
혹은
오, 그렇구나
뭔가 낭만 있으신데요?
네, 뭐 그럴 수도 있고
아님 제가 아직
철이 덜 들어서
그런 거일 수도 있고요
그럴 수도 있고
와 같은
부분 긍정
담아 표지를 활용하여
상대방 말에
일부분을 긍정해주고
본래 대의도를
명확하게 전달해주는 것이
좋습니다
왜냐하면
근데
고전 영화는 좀
지루하지 않아요?
네, 뭐 그럴 수도 있고
아님 막상 봤는데
재밌을 수도 있고요
오래돼도 명작은
명작이니까요
상대방과 내가
완전히 동일한 생각을
가지고 있지 않더라도
저
중경상님이라고
이번에 재개봉한 영화가 있는데
이번 주 모임에 오실래요?
중경상님이요?
아, 들어본 적은
있는 거 같은데
네, 뭐
좋아요
오, 정말요?
사실 저도 원래
영화 좋아했거든요
어떤 면에서는
서로 크게
다르지 않다는
인상을 줄 수 있거든요
두 번째
경청의
두 가지 조건
대화를 할 때
경청을 잘해야 한다는 건
이미 누구나 아는
사실입니다
하지만
막상 경청을 잘하기가
그리
쉬운 일이던가요?
팝콘은 안 드세요?
네, 저는 원래
영화 볼 때
아무것도 안 먹어요
그럼 이건 뭐예요?
아
중경상님 볼 땐
파인애플 통조림을
꼭 먹어줘야 하거든요
이따
좀 나눠드릴게요
됐거든요
근데 다른 부원들은
언제 와요?
다 온 건데요
네?
저희 둘이 다예요?
네, 어쩌다 보니
하긴 뭐
저도 지금 4학년인데
이게 뭐 하고 있는 건지
모르겠네요
가치관이 서로 다른
두 사람을
하나로 연결시켜주는
도구는
대화입니다
그런데 대화가
잘 통하려면
일단 경청부터 할 줄
알아야 하는데요
하지만
생각보다 너무 재밌는데요?
그쵸
진짜 괜찮지 않아요?
네, 진짜 너무 잘 봤어요
근데 생각해보니까
저한테 이런 시간이
좀 필요했던 거 같아요
뭐랄까
현실에서 좀 벗어나는 시간?
그쵸
그런 시간이
종종 필요하긴 하죠
막상 경청을 잘하지 못하는 분들이
은근히 많습니다
상대방이 알아서
잘 떠들어준다면
묵묵히 듣고만 있어도
괜찮지만
그게 아니라면
어색한 침묵만
흐를 뿐이죠
그렇기 때문에
근데 생각해보니까
저한테 이런 시간이
좀 필요했던 거 같아요
경청을 할 때는
딱 이 두 가지에 초점을 두고
경청해주는 것이 좋습니다
첫째
상대방이 말하고 싶은 게 뭘까?
둘째
상대방이 듣고 싶은 말은 뭘까?
우선
상대방이 말하고 싶은 게
뭘까에 초점을 두고
경청하면
저도 예전에는
영화관 진짜 자주 갔었는데
요즘은 너무 치열하게 살아서
이렇게 숨 쉴 여유조차 없었거든요
아, 너무 치열하게 지내셨구나
경청은 한결 편해집니다
왜냐하면
상대방이 말하고 싶어하는 것이
무엇인지
궁금해하는 태도를 가지는 것만으로도
상대방이 알아서
네, 저 정말 치열하게 살았어요
제 스스로가 너무 부족하다고 생각되니까
너무 불안하더라고요
자신이 말하고 싶어하는 것을
말할 겁니다
왜냐하면
누군가 내 이야기를 들어주길 바라는 마음은
아니, 갈증은
좀처럼 해소되지 않는 법이니깐요
아, 많이 불안하셨구나
충분히 그럴 수 있죠
그리고 지금 이 순간
상대방이
가장 듣고 싶어하는
말이 무엇인지에
관심을 두고서
네, 그래서 더 열심히 했던 것 같아요
일단 열심히 하면
뭐라도 될 것 같으니까
근데 말씀하시는 거 들어보니까
느낌이 딱 와요
희진 씨는 분명 잘 되실 거예요
상대방이 그토록 듣고 싶었던
그 말을 해줄 수 있다면
정말 그렇게 생각해요?
별거 아닌 그 짧은 한두 마디가
그 사람에겐
당연하죠
분명 노력한 만큼
좋은 결과가 있을 거예요
진심으로요
생애에 가장 의미 있는
사건이 될 수 있습니다
왜냐하며
아이샤 빌리 상점에서
30관의 풍리를 찾았다
5월 1일 아침에
이 일을 깨닫기 시작했다
아메의 마음속에서
이 풍리만이 좋아
무슨 의미가 있니?
1년 동안
2명이 아메의 사람이라고 들었다고 생각했다
대화는 찰나일지라도
기억은 영원할 수 있거든요
5분 안에 레벨업
비치키를 구독하시고
레벨 버프를 받아가세요